merci à l'académie merci de m'avoir
convié ici aux côtés de certaines des
expériences et des coopérations qui ont
compté le plus dans ma vie je les dis
avant et je vais le répéter
cynthia scarlett charlie saint-roch et
ouais je dois dire c'est un honneur
immense d'être envisagée en votre
compagnie avec karen le réalisateur
hooper ça a été un tel privilège de
travailler à vos côtés
je suis tellement fière de d'apparaître
dans votre film extraordinaire je dois
remercier celles et ceux qui m'ont
soutenu à l'écran mat jeff est réglé
trop ouais quoi chasser buck également
fait nous refusons toute la distribution
toute l'équipe qui a travaillé
d'arrache-pied sur ce film pour célébrer
la vie de johnny hoogerland et je
remercie ma grande famille center kevin
merci pour ses 25 ans
il y avait 25 ans merci d'avoir rêvé
plus grand que jamais j'aurais pu rêver
merci également d'avoir alimenté tout
cela dans le travail dans la joie dans
la reconnaissance à ma famille qui est
venu ici avec rien d'autre que eux même
et le fait de croire au dans le rêve
américain
voilà maintenant à l'oscar jeudi et va
toutes les autres tous les autres merci
de tout l'amour que vous me réservez
pour tout le soutien que vous me donnez
qui fait que j'ai l'impression de penser
que tout est possible et je dois dire ce
soir que cette année et échanges autour
de la célébration de judy garland d' les
générations entre les différentes
cultures également ces échanges ont été
une piqûre de rappel la géniale pour
dire que ses héros ses héroïnes nous
unissent nous inspirent ils nous forcent
à trouver le meilleur au plus profond de
nous mêmes vraiment ces héroïnes et ses
héros nous unissent quand on regarde mer
ses héros et ses héroïnes nous sommes
toutes et tous d'accord et c'est
important pour les respectera venus
serena vie serena williams venus
williams scorsese bob d'hélène angel
harry est tout le soutien toutes et tous
ont sommes d'accord quand il s'agit de
celles et ceux qui nous enseignent des
choses nous sommes d'accord lorsqu'il
s'agit des hommes et des femmes en
uniformes des soldats qui servent
lorsqu'il s'agit également de ceux qui
travaillent dans les premiers secours
les pommiers lorsque nous célébrons les
héros et l'héroïne de notre société
eh bien ça nous rappelle qui nous sommes
nous sommes un seul et même peuple nous
sommes unis vous savez je dis garlande
n'a pas reçu cet honneur à son époque
mais je suis certaine que cet instant
est une extension de la célébration de
son héritage qui a commencé sur le
plateau de tournage de notre film et je
crois que c'est représentatif nice du
fait que son héritage ce qu'elle nous
laisse penser quelque chose
d'exceptionnel d'absolument unique et
puis la dimension inclusive la
générosité de l'esprit je crois tout
cela transcende toutes celles et ceux
qui
ce qu'elle m'a crié artistiquement
madame guerlande sans aucun doute vous
faites partie des héroïnes qui nous
unissent et qui nous définissent et
cette hausse car je vous le dis je suis
tellement reconnaissante merci à toutes
et à tous et excellente soirée
[Musique]